Oh black cab exclusive we got some
classic big out for my man to get on
over shut up world famous builder
recipes the big girl recipes to Whitney
used her we in the building team early
already know how we do okay oh yeah oh
yeah come back kid come back better with
that cup make it come back charter
really [__] I ever wrote matter of fact
I never write different from the rapper
talking about burners they never hold
we're superstars you can see us through
the telescope for they even open the
package up they can tell his dope use
the earth reprimand rapping before I rat
no way is the chit upper right and I
took an oath just got the bends no rooms
i'm showing off telling no i'm showing
proof and they say it comes first so i
put the beamer first before i put the
chin up with the rocky for the watch i
put that Nina how I fire cocaina [__]
the streets Hurricane Katrina never left
the money in the Thames competence in my
[__] day lawyer so I made them
believers imma young rat [__] rich fat
[__] got p90x una be good we get [__]
dick go get [__] full fifth [__]
won't miss [__] mine and Dave Martin
Luther music uplifting iggins modern-day
cassius clay but don't buy stock is pray
just freak [__] better detox dr. Drake
do we find them my nice clean pine box
of Lake underground forever I'm an
underground King got the fro asked
around got [__] round in the treasure
I think around get found in the desert
got the burner with the beam hit them
clean mom blocks away my rock days my
hat you'll aged 30 bricks a week my
after a day so my mind I keep it stopped
in the grave of Arrakis it dependent
never mention is me my name philly free
hey you know I get to pay and you know
I'm holding it down and take it Shay I'm
sure Rosen you know we get the door when
you know we get the Hosen of the mcs fo
yeah you can't touch me ever my name
freeway my foot was too damn clever
flowing off the top and I come on your
block with the clock and take everything
you got you better recognize I'm a
legend ain't no half-stepping I'm in
this building with the weapon you know I
hold it down with bootleg Kevin we take
them whole to the hotel and get him
pregnant psych me joking we never do
that you know we strap up roll back to
the sack I got this fully jacket on in
this real fat goat fat really hot you
can't touch free yeah I got the snap
back on and you know when I get on the
mic I do what I do from dusk till dawn
and I'm off the top and I'm never boring
you'll never snore when I'm on the mic
cuz I'm a good performer tomorrow I'm
gonna be at Cosmo shut down the show so
call up a friend and color ho let's go
yo shout out to my man freeway man he
just he just [__] on everybody's
written raps off the top of his head
right now man tomorrow Kozma pops going
down dunk exchange I'm gonna be live in
the mix I can change so I can't forget
about Duncan's chance you're gonna be in
the building we're gonna shut it down
shut out the logics my man he gonna be
in the building performer to it's going
down be there hitting the stage at nine
o'clock hey thanks for coming through
for anything for blessing to Mike man
anytime it's Ready Set Radio bootleg cat